this was the scene at Berlin's main
train station this morning on an average
day some 300,000 passengers passed
through here things are quite different
here today at this time the day usually
crowds are rushing up this escalator
only a third of all trains is running
and most of the passengers did not show
up and many of those who did are simply
stuck did you know that there is a
strike in Germany no what is that I
don't know I'm feeling bad because we we
were very organized and we we had a gem
that you follow and now we are we are
losing everything and we already paid I
hope it's only in Germany because I've
got a number of the stops to go to I'm
on a tour and from here to Ukraine more
preparation would have been required
strikes should hurt but when it affects
you personally it's not very pleasant so
many passengers are angry the strike was
announced at such short notice just a
day in advance in fact the walkout has
left many tourists stranded many of them
did not find out in time to make
alternative arrangements there are some
trains still running but it's only a
third of the usual number and these
trains are urgently needed because
alternatives are rare organized car
pools and buses are mostly booked and
flying on such a strike day is
especially expensive and so some people
are trying their luck here in spite of
the strike
some passengers are choosing to travel
on two wheels instead one cloud as it
work we'll see I'm not convinced I'm
holding a talk it'd be nice if it worked
out it's a two and a half hour journey
instead of a 60 minute ride we recently
began traveling by train again initially
we were impressed
but if we go touring cities again we'll
go by car for deutsche bahn the repeated
strike action is a loss of face
representatives warned the action could
cause lasting damage to the rail
operators image that's our bitter
experience many customers no longer see
the train as a reliable mode of
transport these people switch to long
distance buses or take the car auto
passengers using the few trains that are
still running need to be patient
their journeys are likely to be much
longer and more complicated than usual